[Music]
I think that the teacher and a leader
they're all together you know I don't
think of them as distinct parts of what
I do when I run the lab I feel like I'm
teaching the graduate students and the
postdocs partly by example partly we're
all in this together and and I think
that they they go together my hope is
that when people leave this lab you know
there are stronger better person people
there that they're leaders themselves
and and that in fact has happened I mean
we have over 300 people who have left
the lab or professors who lead their own
lab we've had many people leave the lab
who have become presidents of companies
who've started their own companies
who've become CEOs so they've become
leaders and and that's what I love to
say well I don't know that there's any
one set of qualities that I've seen
leaders succeed in different ways but I
mean to me the kinds of things I think
I'd probably do are try to impart to the
people who work for me or work with me
the fact that you want to make an impact
on the world you want to make it a
better place you want to treat people
well and and and and and and and you
want to really think that almost
anything is possible and and I guess
finally the way I try to deal with
people for the most part is try to
provide what I'll call positive
reinforcement if somebody does something
good I want to let them know it rather
than say yelling at them and saying you
should work harder I want people to work
hard because they want to not because
they have to well well the way I try to
foster this this idea of discovery and
invention is is partly by example is is
and you know if somebody comes in and
they're doing a thesis I try to get them
to think about well what will be
important I might shape it you know in
some very general way but I want people
to just think I don't I don't want to
just say here do this I die I want to be
a guide another way I sometimes think
about it is this because I'm dealing
with graduate students and postdocs and
something so the way I offer
think about it is if somebody is a
graduate student or a postdoctoral
fellow almost their entire life up till
then
they've been judged shaped by grades or
other means by how well they give
answers to other people's questions but
in life in my opinion what's really
important is not the answers as that you
might give though that's important but
the really important thing is the
questions you ask are you asking really
important questions or are you asking
medium important questions or
unimportant questions I think the key to
it is to help somebody go from somebody
who gives good answers to somebody who
asks good questions because in the end
questions are going to be what's key you
know so that that's really what I want
to say
[Music]